the Lord and Christopher Miller have
said the Lego Batman movie is one giant
Easter Egg for Batman aficionados and
the film really is totally packed with
DC Comics movie and P V Easter eggs in
jokes and references yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers it's Jan here and in this video
I'm going to take a look at all the best
Easter eggs and references I spotted in
the movie I'm also giving away this
awesome pair of Lego Batman movie books
that's the essential guide clip this
very cool making of the movie which is
stuffed with concept art sketches and
Lego builds for a chance to win make
sure you subscribe and leave a comment
on this video about your favorite Easter
Egg or any I missed just before I start
quick warning there are spoilers ahead
so if you're not ready for those pail
your nearest that would be allowed of
here by capping or clicking the screen
to my spoiler free review of the movie
let's start with Harley Quinn who has
the word smile X written on the front of
her costumes which is an easter egg the
poison the Joker used to terrorize
Gotham in the 1989 Batman movie in that
film Jack Nicholson's Joker laced
various products throughout Gotham with
smile X which would cause victims to
laugh uncontrollably until they died
with a frozen grin on their face and
when pilot Bill reminds the Joker that
Batman has always foiled his plans like
that time with the prince music and the
parade it's another hat tip to that
first Batman movie by Tim Burton where
the Joker plays Prince music during a
parade he organized to offer free cash
to the citizens of Gotham while secretly
planning to unleash my next gas on
everyone there's another reference to
the 1989 Batman movie when Lego Batman
says let's get nuts after the Joker
challenges him at the Gotham energy
facility which echoes the time Michael
Keaton's Bruce Wayne flew into a rage
with a Joker in the 89 Batman movie and
said those very same words The Dark
Knight movie also gets referenced by the
pilot when he reminds the Clown Prince
of Crime about that time with a to boat
what he's talking about is the dilemma
that Heath Ledger's Joker set up in that
movie when he loaded two ferries with
explosives offering each boat the choice
to blow the other one up or both be
destroyed and it was a brilliant bit of
meta humor when the pilots requesting
permission to fly over the most
crime-ridden city in the world with a
plane
packed with explosives were working for
none other than look up in Airlines the
movie also references Batman's origin
for a family for
so outside the monarch theatre where
Bruce Wayne and his parents visited the
night that his parents were murdered the
streets of Lego Gotham are also littered
with Easter eggs hidden in building
names and billboards first up is the
iceberg lounge a nightclub from the
comics that's run by the penguin and
used as a front for his illegal
activities the big belly burger chain
also operates in Lego Batman Gotham big
belly burger has featured regularly in
the flash and arrow TV shows and first
appeared in The Adventures of Superman
comic book series in 1988 another sign
on the building is the name Magnus which
could be a nod to the comic book
character will Magnus a genius robotic
scientist and creator of the Metal Men
when Superman is being interviewed on TV
people are watching the program outside
a school called Wendel's electronics in
the comics wendell Lewis was the sewer
King and operated a criminal underworld
in Gotham sewers and during that Gotham
City news TV broadcast Man of Steel
director Zack Snyder gets a visual
shout-out when the footage being shown
is credited as courtesy of Zack Snyder
and a mockery a mere mockery by the way
was the cinematographer for Man of Steel
among the movies showing at the movie
theater in Gotham is one called two
shades of grey a joke and reference to
the facts of the Fifty Shades of Grey
movie sequels fifty shades darker is
released on the same day as a Lego
Batman movie Gotham sister-city
blüdhaven gets referenced in the Lego
Batman movie and there's a clever double
Easter egg and joke in the name of the
Bloodhound Express first bloodhound is
not only a word play on the Greyhound
bus lines it's also a nod to the DC
Comics intergalactic criminal bloodhound
and possibly also to blüdhaven faithful
team the bloodhounds the adven Laszlo's
ham with a picture of a butcher wearing
a pig's mask is a nice reference to
Laszlo Valentin aka Professor pig from
the comics
professor pig is a particularly unhinged
Batman villain who is obsessed with
trying to make people perfect in the
movie The Joker also hijacks one of
Laszlo slaughterhouse trucks to break
into the Gotham power plant there's also
a billboard for zesty Cola one of the
two big soda manufacturers in the DC
Comics universe and zestes main rival
soda Cola also pops up later on another
billboard the tiny little ad for kettle
coffee on the top of the yellow cab a
reference
a DC Comics writer an Inca coal kettle
kettle worked on numerous Superman
titles and created a modern version of
Superboy and was also assigned for
Chandra's which could be an easter egg
to metahuman Chandrakant solving clinic
which Bruce Wayne attended in the comics
teen band the flips you've appeared in a
number of Teen Titans comics show up on
a billboard in Gotham City and Ferris
air the aviation company that employs
Hal Jordan aka Green Lantern appears
numerous times in the movie there are
billboards and ads for the company
throughout Gotham as well as Ferris air
aeroplanes at the airport
the villain plastique seems to have her
own perfume range in the lego universe
with a billboard for classic perform
there's also a night wink to the
upcoming lego ninjago movie visor
billboard Vernon Jago town the name and
design is also very cool a march to the
1974 movie Chinatown which of course
starred Jack Nicholson the Joker in 1989
Batman movie Batman also carries a pair
of Ninjago Jade blades which were paired
on Legos and Jago TV series and Batman's
excessive utility belt which has been
poked fun at over the years gets a funny
moment when he unloads it before going
through Arkham Asylum security systems
as well as a huge utility belt logo
Batman also has a huge ego which extends
to a rivalry with Iron Man perhaps one
of his greatest current cinematic rivals
both being billionaire playboy
philanthropist with a shedload of
high-tech gear at their disposal
hilariously the password for access to
the Batcave is not other than Iron Man
sucks there's a few times in the movie
when Batman refers to Bruce Wayne as
Bruno Rosalind Bruce which is a nod to
how in numerous spanish-speaking
countries Bruce Wayne is actually called
Bruno Diaz and as you'd expect the
Batcave is still to bursting with Easter
eggs references and jokes
starting with the bat suits white bat is
Batman camouflage bat suit from the
comics that he used in snowy places like
the North Pole here's a passage of turn
on Smokey Robinson song tears of a clown
and fat by Gaslight is a nod to the
single-issue comic books Gotham by
Gaslight Krampus fat refers to the half
demon half goat mythological figure that
punishes badly behaved children around
Christmastime raging bat comes complete
with boxing gloves and is referenced in
Martin school say
movie Raging Bull starring Robert De
Niro as the boxer Jake LaMotta and the
night terror suit is likely a nod to the
Batman night terror series in the new 52
the Batcave is also full of fat man's
crazy vehicles including the fat Serbs
of that space shuttle the bat Zeppelin
the bat train the bat kayak and the bat
dune buggie there are stacks of
Batmobiles in the Batcave and there's an
Easter Egg to Batmobile designer George
Barris by the ad for Barris automotive
on the back of the brick magazine that
Bruce Wayne pulls out to the police
collar event George Barris created the
first design for the 60s TV show
Batmobile the bat garage also includes
some crafty Easter eggs for example
there's a plaque to the company oval
oils which one sponsored the comic book
superhero team the conglomerate and was
a funny moment in the Batcave when Dick
Grayson spots of that shark repellent
which Batman says is completely useless
this is a little joke about the shark
repellent bat spray from the 1966 Batman
movie the shark repellent from that
movie has been Lampoon's many times
however later in the lego batman movie
the spray does actually work when lego
jaws attacks Batman and the 1960s Batman
TV show gets tons of fun references on
marshes and jokes all the way through
Lego Batman
the iconic theme tune is referenced
throughout for example Lego Batman
opening song who's the Batman has the
Batman refrain shown by the backing
fingers as well as a repeated line
nananananananana Batman and there's more
risk later on for example when Batman
refuses to go to the police Carla with a
string of no no no no no no no no I also
loved hearing Batman say to the
Batmobile with Robin responding
hot-diggity-dog followed up with a LEGO
version of the TV shows bat logo scene
transition Robin cheesy holy Batman
phrases from the TV show also gettin odd
with Robins holy family photos after his
selfie with Batman Batgirl and Alfred
the bat fight words from the 60s show
and movie also pop up as Batman and
Robin say they're going to hit the bad
guys so hard it will make words appear
on the screen and when Alfred puts on a
LEGO version of Adam West blue and grey
bat suit he says it's because he misses
the 60s later Alfred reveals that he
used to be a tail gunner which is a nod
to both the time he served in the Royal
Air Force in the comics
also to the fact that alfred in the
upcoming Justice League movie will be a
tower gunner on the flying fox by the
way when Alfred and Robin had to take
out the gremlins trying to destroy their
craft it's a hat tip to the origin of
the word gremlin an RAF pilot slang for
the pilots attributed fault from their
planes to impish little creatures at
sabotage aircraft and who they called
gremlins Barbara Gordon also references
many of the major moments in Batman's
lengthy history when she said in her
speech that Batman's been on the job a
very long time a series of pictures from
all the major Batman films show up
including the 1940 serials and also
various iconic comic book covers such as
Frank Miller's The Dark Knight Returns
and Barbara Gordon herself gets a
brand-new backstory in Lego Batman which
the filmmakers themselves have said
deviate from the DC canon to a
ridiculous degree it turns out the
Barbara Gordon trained at Harvard for
police and then cleaned up the crime
ridden blüdhaven with statistics to suit
ups Barbara Gordon as Batgirl Batman
uses that mirch gun trying out a number
of costumes on her one of them is fat
lady which could be a reference to the
fictional bat lady comic book character
from the 1955 musical comedy artists and
models which starred Dean Martin and
Jerry Lewis the bat lurch gunman hits
Barbara Gordon with a pink battery 'no
outfit and then a soccer mum costume
both of which he hates eventually she
gets a cool costume that has the feel of
a Vaughn Craig's Batgirl costume from
the 60s TV series the Lego Batman movie
also plays fast and loose with a history
of batgirls relationship with Batman in
the comics with Batman joking at the end
of the movie that Batgirl is this
platonic co-worker buddy through the
girl but just a friend for the Wonder
Boy Robin there are plenty of nods and
Easter eggs to his comic book and screen
history when Dick Grayson approaches
Bruce Wayne to ask what qualities will
get him adopted too he mentions are
cooking in gymnastic abilities on the
Teen Titans TV series Dick Grayson is a
great sandwich maker and his acrobatic
skills and circus background are
mentioned in both the comics and on
screen for instance in Batman Forever if
you look closely you'll also spot a line
of Robins on dick Grayson's jumper a
nice bit of detail ahead of his later
suggestions that you take on the
superhero nickname of Robin Robins
transformation into Nightwing later in
the movie while Batman is stuck
the Phantom Zone reflects how he grew
out as being Batman's sidekick in the
comics and into that new role Michael
Cera who plays Robin also starred
alongside Lego Batman's Will Arnett in
the TV comedy series Arrested
Development and the nice shout-out to
Sarah's character on that show George
Michael Bluth when Robin suggest various
superhero theme songs he plays ones wake
me up before you go-go switch was
written produced and sung by none other
than George Michael one of the roles
which zach galifianakis voices a joker
is most famous for his Allen in the
hangover movie trilogy and there's a
subtle nod to that character and Robin
kicks the guy just outside a Joker's
cell in Arkham Asylum saying to paint
that Allen joel schumacher's Batman
Forever gets quite a lot of shoutouts in
the Lego Batman movie from fireworks to
a Batman Forever bat suit and a Batman
Forever placard and Christopher Nolan's
Batman trilogy also gets numerous
references for example when Batman is
doing a series of push-ups while alfred
lectures him it's rather similar to when
alfred is lecturing christian bale's
Bruce Wayne while he does push-ups in
Batman Begins and the reference to Bruce
Wayne and Russian ballerinas is a nod to
the time in the dark night when Bruce
Wayne went off on a ship with the
Russian ballet as a cover for his
planned operation in Hong Kong Batgirl
and Lego Batman tipped her hat the
brutal magic trick that Heath Ledger's
Joker performed to the pencil when she
says to Baltimore want to see a magic
trick I'm going to make you disappear
and she sends him back to the Phantom
Zone and Bane in the movie not only
sounds like Tom Hardy's Bane from The
Dark Knight Rises but he also risks from
one of Fame's lines when he cries we
will be the Joker's reckoning by the way
the hijacking of MacGuffin airlines at
the beginning of the movie has shades of
the opening to the Dark Knight Rises
were bane henchmen hijacked a plane
where he's being held the most recent
live-action Batman movie was of course
Batman V Superman and there are some
hilarious nods to that film first up is
the music during the opening titles
because a definite touch of the dramatic
drum theme from BBS ass Batman pokes fun
at the various logos the Batman Superman
rivalry is played up when the DC logo
appears and fat man brags DC the house
of Batman bills and in the movie Batman
even taunts Superman saying come at me
bro
I'm your kryptonite there's also a funny
flashback that the lego recreation of
the confrontation
between Batman and Superman in dawn of
justice despite this rivalry Batman
still ends up paying Superman a visit
that he needs to seal the Phantom Zone
projector from the fortress of solitude
and is a brilliant audio Easter egg when
Batman rings Superman's doorbell and it
plays with Superman theme by John
Williams if you are wondering about the
large arrow symbol on the entrance to
the fortress of solitude well it's a
little joke about the big arrow shaped
key that Superman's sometimes used to
secure access to the fortress of
solitude in the comics once inside
Batman discovered Superman is having a
Justice League 57th anniversary party a
reference to the fact that the Justice
League first appeared 57 years ago in
1960 in issue 28 ooh The Brave and the
bold comic book as when Batman takes the
photos the Justice League they all say
Superfriends a reference to the animated
TV series that aired in the 1970s and
80s and which adapt is adjusted lead
characters for TV by the way when the
dog who DJ's at the party has a green
cape just like Wonder dog from the
Superfriends animated TV series inside
the fortress Batman accidentally
activates a hologram of Superman's
father jor-el in a hilarious moments as
Batman just ignores Darrell's message
about the crystal that he's destroying
containing irreplaceable knowledge the
atomic cauldron is a nod to the cauldron
which powers of fortress in the comics
Batman has a job at the recent Suicide
Squad movie when he scoffs about why he
would use one group of criminals to
defeat another group of criminals and as
a shout-out to Harley Quinn's alter ego
psychiatrist dr. Harleen Quinzel from
the Phantom Zone laundry truck which
reads operated by Quinzel on one of the
doors talking of psychiatrists the
author of the book setting limits for
your out-of-control child which Alfred
is reading is none other than dr.
Bartholomew Wolper dr. Wolper appeared
in Frank Miller's graphic novels The
Dark Knight Returns as a doctor who
claims that Batman's extreme vigilantism
and disregard of criminals rights was
the cause of the Joker's insanity
ironically Walker met his end at the
hands of the Joker when he tried to
prove this live on TV and when Batman
has to confront the joke in a Hall of
Mirrors back at Wayne Manor which the
Joker has converted into a theme park
it's a nod to the Dark Knight Returns
comic and the showdown between Batman
and the Joker which occurs in a house of
mirrors at an amusement park
Michael Jack
song man in the mirror appears and forms
the basis of numerous gags throughout
the movie it's interesting that a
Michael Jackson track plays such an
important part in the Lego Batman movie
as Jackson and Prince who were both big
Batman fans were actually supposed to
collaborate on the music with Tim
Burton's 1989 Batman film Lego Batman's
favorite movie seems to be Jerry Maguire
and he loves laughing at the line new
complete moves which relates to the
theme of Batman finding friendship and
family in the film and also to his
dysfunctional relationship with the
Joker on top of that it's also a wink at
the Joker's you completely lying to
Batman in the Dark Knight which itself
was a nod to Jerry Maguire indeed Renee
Zellweger famous line you had me at
hello is also parodied at the end of
Lego Batman's when the Joker says to
Batman you had me at shut up the Lego
movies infinite abyss of nothingness
gets a shout-out when dr. Quivers comes
on TV and explains how Gotham is built
on a bunch of flimsy plates or two stuck
together and under which is an infinite
abyss now I'd love to hear what other
Easter eggs in jokes or references you
spotted in the Lego Batman movie and
which was your favorite don't forget to
leave a comment and subscribe for a
chance to win this awesome pair of Lego
Batman movie book and if you're
wondering about all those Batman villain
and Justice League cameos click or tap
here to check out my guide to all the
celebrity and hidden cameos in the movie
or take a look at some of my other
videos you might like do turn on your
notifications for flicks in the city so
you can catch my new videos thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers